régine on a tout dit tout raconté
parfois tout inventé à votre sujet vous
avez été tour à tour pour le populaire
et pour le snob un personnage mythique
accablé de légende merveilleux et
grotesque superficiel et profond on vous
a offert un nom dhombres et d'insomnie
google de nuit peut-être parce qu'il y
avait du gabin dans votre tempérament
les journalistes qui ont la plume facile
et la phrase amical
vous prête désert de fréhel et de
mistinguett en somme la tête et les
jambes
aux premières heures de votre carrière
régine vous passiez pour une juno
polonaise
qui aurait été élevée du côté du canal
saint martin lorsque vous avez tenté
l'irrésistible ascension de paris vous
étiez impossible plus faubourienne que
l'on front du faubourg plus noble que
marie-chantal plus ambitieuse que tous
les cadeaux de paris il a fallu que
vienne le succès pour que vous ne
trichez plus et nous sommes convenus de
croire régine qu'en vérité le plus dur
c'est d'être soi-même aujourd'hui vous
êtes régine et j'ai l'impression régine
que vous ne vous forcez plus bon alors
j'ai écouté tout ce qu'on m'avait dit je
dois dire que dans tout ce qui tous que
ce que vous venez de dire jacques il ya
beaucoup de choses devrait alors
reprendre repartons à la première
période en report la régine
c'est du nom polonaise comme eux vous
vous dites si bien dire qu'il me va très
bien
impossible et et en même temps très vrai
parce que j'ai toujours été très vrai
avait à ce moment là qu'un seul but
c'était celui de réussir
ce qu'elles aiment entreprises et
lorsque j'avais entrepris je vais parler
à ma petite personne ce que j'avais
entreprises c'est-à-dire un club de nuit
car c'était l'ouverture pour moi sur
quelque chose où j'étais bien dans ma
peau c'est à dire la nuit chez une
octobre il c'est vrai
je suis une puce d'un personnage
mythique bien sûr comme tous les
personnages à qui on accorde énormément
de deux légendes
je n'ai jamais cherché à les effacer
cette inutile et ça me servais je ne
vois pas pourquoi j'aurais été contre ça
en plus de ça les gps les les
personnages qui n'ont pas de légende
n'intéresse personne bien
impossible ce n'est pas le mot quand on
nous de faire un endroit comme celui
puisqu'on en est à la première période
de la régine quand on avait fait un
endroit comme celui je veux faire y'a
pas de problème il faut jouer à un jeu
comme quelqu'un qui veut lancer un
produit décide de quelle politique
tout lisons que j'ai joué un jeu précis
sens mais qui me ressemblaient qui fait
partie d'une des régimes que je suis
la nuit de la vie de noctambule et la
vie de nuit plus exactement d'une chose
très dur contrairement à tout ce qu'on
raconte est surtout quand on le voit de
l'autre côté j'ai été pendant très
longtemps une fille qui fréquentaient
les boîtes de nuit qui dansaient game
amusée comme une folle qui voyait pas du
tout les choses enfin de l'autre côté de
la barre sérieux tous comment c'est pas
sérieux tout ça comment s'est passé
votre sérieux je vais 17 ans 18 ans tu
es de montage tout à l'heure j'entendais
une mission sur george sand vous disais
qu'il fallait que les gens apprennent à
danser au fait qu'on interdit à toute la
jeunesse leur interdit d'aller danser or
il n'y a pas de problème là dedans c'est
un défoulement est un moyen de faire
connaissance de marché bien d'être
élégant moi j'étais une fille très forte
et disons que la danse m'a permis de
passer au travers de plus une vie d'une
certaine vie en 25 6 ans si vous voulez
en étant forte et en donnant une
apparence de faux pas une part quand
j'avais une légèreté une facilité et que
ça m'a donné beaucoup d'assurance dans
la vie c'est d'une ultime question de la
danse surprend c'est gentil je vais
arriver un petit point d'avancé j'ai
entendu dans cette émission sur jean le
sens
disons que j'aime la danse j'aurais
voulu être danseuse je voulais être
chanteuse c'était mon ambition quand il
était gosse
que la vie mieux
que j'ai mené pendant la guerre
une vie sans parents un petit peu livrée
à moi-même a fait que j'ai pris des
responsabilités une assurance très vite
bien sûr parce qu'il fallait que je me
défende comme tous les gens qui ont
besoin de se défendre on devient un
petit peu mystérieuse c'est à dire qu'on
ne se raconte pas facilement
on te raconte pas facilement parce qu'on
pense que c'est inutile et que
quelquefois n'y a que les gifles qui
font comprendre les choses qu'ils ont
j'ai appris à me défendre plus vite avec
les points qu'en parlant pendant une
certaine période je parle de mon enfance
car j'ai été dans des pensions dans des
endroits plus ou moins que j'avais je
n'avais pas choisi et que c'était un
petit peu une survie
une survie avec la méchanceté des
enfants enfin qu on a tout ce que
j'avais moi que les autres avaient
faisait huit mois que j'avais vis-à-vis
d'eux sûrement donc si vous voulez sera
préparé cette régine qui est arrivé tout
d'un coup qui a retrouvé
son père et qui a mené une existence un
petit peu bizarre c'est à dire que mon
père vin café restaurant à belleville
déjà le music hall à côté il y avait les
folies belleville et que j'étais four et
tous les soirs dans ses folies
belleville ses folies belleville était
presque un lien avec un couvent avec ce
en provence dans lequel je vivais par la
guerre où mon père m'avait caché ce que
vous le savez je suis juive et j'étais
la seule petite vivre dans un couvent
régé ne pas lui est plus que
la noctambule plus que la chanteuse ce
qui m'intéresse c'est la femme que vous
êtes devenu ai je l'impression que si
vous aviez été dans l'époque de proust
vous auriez été l'un de ses personnages
vous êtes régine vous vous êtes fait un
prénom alors que tout le monde essaie de
se faire un nom si mon nom en plus c'est
votre nom en plus mon prénom mon vrai
prénom mais la véritable origine et ce
qu'elle existe la véritable origine
existe dans chaque chose qu'elle fait y
ait pas de problème je voulais vous
finir ce lien pour revenir à
l'artistique il y avait des folies
belleville à côté et pendant la guerre
pendant cette guerre où j'étais dans ce
couvent mon père n'avait rien à faire
c'était la fameuse zone libre était très
joueurs
et s'ils voulaient le samedi et dimanche
je passais mon temps sur les banquettes
du casino d'aix-en-provence
je voyais mon père rentré dans cette
porte tournante on a le droit d'entrée
qu'à partir de 21 ans ou si on est marié
et puis je l'envoyais jamais sortir mais
par contre il y avait des spectacles où
tout le monde passe et c'était en 41 est
il vrai que votre père qui était
tellement joueur avait même oublié votre
naissance oui mon père mon père qui
était tellement joueurs ils avaient
raison c'était l'une de ses passions je
crois qu'on doit faire dans la vie ce
qu'on a envie il a fait tout ce qu'ils
avaient envie les eu raison je suis les
25 décembre mon père a toujours été
fâché que les papiers je vais vous dire
que quand ils étayent les polonais il a
vécu il est un petit peu il était
pâtissier au départ et il a été
pâtissier sur des bateaux qui partaient
en argentine et tout j'ai des fabricants
l'argentine qu'il a monté une
boulangerie en belgique je suis né le 25
décembre et joue aux cartes les mairies
été fermés c'était fait et ma foi comme
il était fâché avec l'écriture c'est un
petit peu trop compliqué pour lui et
login me reconnaître vous lui reprochez
journal seulement pas absolument pas je
trouve que tout ce qui s'est passé
antérieurement dans ma vie à aider à
fabriquer cette c'est régine enfin cette
origine peu violente un peu triste un
peu si on porte tous contraire votre
bagarreuse enlever tout ce bagarreur
dans la vie ou alors c'est tout envie
qu'une fois il faut il faut vivre il
faut
il faut recevoir des coups ils feront
donné il faut 50 cc moral vous avez d
une fois une chose qui vous définit bien
et cette société ce qui m'épate ce n'est
pas ce qui m'arrive mais ce qu'il y a eu
avant le léman je le maintiens c'est
parce qu'il m'arrive parce que ce qui
m'arrive j'en suis lucide je le décide
un petit peu je dis bon alors je
travaille je peux te dire je mets des
heures à disposition de ce travail que
je fabrique est évidemment rien résultat
parce que j'aime ça et ça dans la peau
et que tout ce que j'entreprends je ne
vais pas au delà de mes possibilités
c'est à dire je ne vais pas me lancer
sur la scène de l'opéra en tutu
et faire le lac des cygnes enfin ou noir
non mais j'ai fait des choses qui sont
dedans mais dans mes cordes je considère
que je suis en médium encore
actuellement que je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
donné car je ne veux pas le donner
maintenant tout ce que j'ai envie de
donner je le donnerai dans peu de temps
et je n'ai pas encore donné régine
lorsque vous dites j'étais une petite
juive vous le dites avec un ton qui
semble me faire croire que vous avez
souffert
j'en ai beaucoup souffert pas pendant la
première période c'est à dire cette
période de couvent où j'étais protégé de
tout je me rendais pas très bien compte
à part je ne faisais pas la même chose
que les autres petites filles je ne
communiquait pas et je les voyais passer
avec un air exotique me disais oh là là
mais ça qu'est ce que ça doit être bon
vraiment je voudrais bien et je me suis
rendu compte que j'étais pas d'âme de la
même religion pour moi être juif c'est
une religion on parle beaucoup de ce
problème de race de religion
personnellement je considère ça comme
une religion et
ça m'agace beaucoup pendant qu'on quand
on parle
du problème juif comme du nas c'est
quand même une religion tout part de
cette religion qui s'est brisée et qui
est allé dans plusieurs sens et pour moi
c'est une oblige c'est à dire que vous
êtes croyants de mai vous n'êtes pas
juive au point de partir pour israël
vous battre
c'est tout à fait prêt de partir de
partir en israël me battre si vraiment
il y avait un tel déclenchement
comme celui qu'il y ait eu pendant la
guerre de 40 bien sûr gérer
immédiatement
réagir que si on attaquait de nouveau
avec la même force et la même
car c'est on n'a plus droit au xxème
siècle ça n'existe plus vous sentez j'ai
eues en israël
non parce que non moi j'ai choisi la
france les choisit librement
je suis at it est en fait je veux dire
j'ai beau être né en belgique de parents
polonais
être un personnage comme ça je suis
absolument je me sens et titi
parisien je suis sûr je serai pas du
tout pillé en israël je veux dire que je
ne vivrai pas tout le temps mais je suis
capable d'aller en israël pour pour
aider à quelque chose de précis
je ne veux pas faire de politique sur
israël parce que ces propos d' idiot oui
non en fait je ne veux pas dépasser
le personnage d'origine donc je dis ce
que je pense vis-à-vis
si un jour israël a besoin de moi je
serai là voilà justement vous parlez de
politique
vous êtes sensible à la politique
écoutez moi je me suis pas intéressé la
politique on veut et et j'y comprends
pas grand chose
pourquoi parce que ça n'est pas une
affaire de femmes
non non je dis pas ça je crois que les
femmes ont une grande de vous rassurer
quand une grande vision précise quand
elles veulent se mettre à la politique
je crois que je suis même pour qu'une
femme devienne un jour président de la
république a pas de raison mais
ça sera sans doute pas moi je le
regrette mais
la politique disons m'intéresse
maintenant ça m'a mis en face à ma muse
et ça m'inquiète bien sûr comme tous les
gens mais c'est un duel dans le fond
devrait pas envoyer les gens se battre
si des chefs d'état décident de faire la
guerre depuis le fasse avec une partie
d'échecs des chèques ou qui se battent
en duel ou qu'il fasse j'ai pas mon
exploit quelconque origine pendant toute
une longue partie de votre vie vous avez
joué un jeu aujourd'hui est-ce que vous
jouez encore non je n'ai jamais joué
c'est très difficile à expliquer je
viendrai vous expliquer l'approché vous
expliquer la première partie de mon
existence et puis après y ait eu les
chansons les chansons peut pas mentir
avec des chansons tant que j'ai été sept
régine de la nuit le chalet des
interviews en fin de compte je disais ce
qui me passait par la tête un jour
j'étais bien luné un jour j'étais mal
luné peut un jour le ton
à de la personne qui m'a interviewé me
plaisait pas où les questions plaisait
pas alors je voulais le choquer ou
je le faisais volontiers et je ne le
cache pas mais
je veux pas une provocatrice de façon
disons qu'on est venus souvent de
provoquer parce que justement vous êtes
cette réputation de violence et que ça
ça donne envie à certaines personnes
d'aller cette violence était pour vous
défendre non mais une violence comme ça
de langage et d
excessive j'ai appris que c'est si je
suis plus une polonaise
avec un sang vif et dia par tout le
temps et puis je j'assume ce que je suis
enfin je veux dire j'ai pas du tout
envie de tricher je suis une regina
plusieurs facettes parce que
je peux tomber en larmes dans deux
minutes parce que tout d'un coup vous il
y aura un mot qui va me blesser ou une
je crois que votre atout majeur dans la
vie c'est votre oeil
mon oeil pour beaucoup oui dans parce
que je regarde les gens fassent et
j'aime qu'on me regarde of vous voyez
juste je vois très juste les gens ne me
trompe pas ne trompe pas c'est à dire
que je les regarde je les écoute parler
et si vous voulez
souvent je reste avec des gens qui n'ont
rien de spécial habillage des écoutes
j'écoute volontairement
avec six mois compte de leur vie qui est
assez simple assez tranquille ou alors
complètement bête comme ça mais tout ça
est formidable car chacun chacun choisit
son existence selon son tempérament
et selon ce qu'ils ont envie de vivre
moi j'ai besoin d'une existence
agité mouvementée j'ai besoin d'être
inquiète une l'angoissé
j'ai besoin d'être en colère si tout va
bien je me dis que ça y est tout est
fini je recule
et dans le fond
j'ai peut-être besoin qu'on m'attaque a
quel age origins avez vous commencé à
gagner votre vie à 12 ans
à 12 ans à lyon s'était tout de suite
après la libération fait disons 13 ans à
peu près je devais avoir 13 ans et
mon père revenait pas et j'étais très
inquiète je vivais dans un refuge de
vieillard
les gars étaient finis et puis un jour
j'ai vu arriver un monsieur avec des
béquilles
et c'était mon père et puis il est parti
à paris il me dit je reviens de chercher
dans le bijou récit mois sont passés et
il est parvenu
je me sentais très mal parce que j'étais
chez des gens qui n'étaient pas mes
parents j'ai réalisé à ce moment là tout
ce qui se passait et je me suis dit que
je voulais travailler et j'ai été au
secours national
demander une place de dactylo ce que
j'avais appris la dactylo et
le monsieur qui m'a reçue m'a demandé de
lui raconter pourquoi mon âge je venais
demander une place alors je lui dis
voilà je vais raconter un peu mon
existence il m'a dit écoutez vraiment
voulait plus rester chez ces gens j'ai
dit non je veux plus rester parce que je
me sens une charge
je me sens pas bien il faut que ce
travail il faut que je prenne une
responsabilité on est allé voir ces gens
qui sont vivants quand une blanchisserie
à lyon
et avec qui je suis toujours
en correspondance où je vais les voir
chaque fois que j'en ai l'occasion
et je suis venu chez lui et j'étais non
pas une petite bonne ce que ce n'était
pas le mot mais disons j'ai conduit ses
petites filles à l'école que je leur
apprenais ali
origine chercheurs savaient lire écrire
très bien que vous avez appris que m'en
aller au collège j'étais dans un couvent
était dans des écoles ou c'est selon les
périodes de richesse de mon père j'avais
dans une école très bien où j'allais à
l'école communale enfin c'était c'était
toujours la douche écossaise régine si
les choses ne s'étaient pas passées
ainsi aujourd'hui vous auriez peut-être
une petite bourgeoise c'est ce que je
voulais vous dire vous dire que ce n'est
pas mener cette vie dans le fond
disons que l'exemple de la vie un peu
dissolue et bohème et
dramatique par moments de mon père
m'aurait plutôt donné le temps
d'ensérune bourgeois c'est à dire marier
avoir des enfants à rester dans un coin
et souvent je me souvent je me suis dit
régine il faut pas que tu ne faut pas
que tu fasses ça il faut pas c'est parce
que c'est pas ma nature et j'ai lutté si
vous voulez c'est très étrange que je
vais dire quand je suis donné des coups
de pied au derrière car en fin de compte
je suis d'un tempérament assez sauvage
et timide ce qui donne souvent les plus
grand culot et je devenais un coup de
pied au derrière souvent pour sortir le
soir
seuls aller à saint germain en fait
toutes les choses qui m'ont amené si
vous voulez être ce que je suis enfin
vous n'êtes pas une petite bourgeoise
mais vous pouvez vous préparer à être
une bonne bourgeoise puisque vous allez
vous marier écouter le mariage n'est pas
la bourgeoisie le mariage est un acte
un acte consenti entre deux personnes
est alors vraiment je trouve ça laid pas
péjoratif le mot bourges maintenant j'ai
pas là vous ça veut dire quoi vous
préparez les bourgeois tout en sortant
toutes les nuits ou alors on est
plein bras moi ce que je veux enfin ce
que j'espère avoir et ce que je pense
avoir est ce que j'espère donner à marie
c'est une incompréhension une
une confiance totale entre deux êtres
qui équipe qui parlent ensemble qu'ils
ont des choses à dire qu'ils rient
pleurent qui ofaj mois qu'ils veulent
former une famille
former une famille oui bien sûr vous
savez que j'ai un fils que j'étais
mariée au fils qui est un grand jeune
homme comme se marier très très jeune
pour partir très vite de chez moi en
grande partie
et quand j'étais marié c'était gg fait
le reste pour partir très vite de debon
de mon foyer conjugal non pas parce que
mon mari était un mauvais mari car ces
fausses tel un garçon extraordinaire je
les aime beaucoup et sûrement 6 me
demander en mariage aujourd'hui je
dirais oui aussi je veux dire que le
personnage était
formidable avait 16 ans il en avait 19
en été un petit peu un petit peu jeune
il maintenait ce café restaurant mon
père qui lui avait récupéré sa confiture
ips mon père une confiturerie
et que la vie nous a malmenés tous les
deux et qu'on n'était pas assez costaud
pour
supporter tout ce qui se passait régine
vous aimez régine
oui
régine est ce que vous croyez à l'au
delà est ce que pour vous dieu est un
refuge
écoutez vous me posez une question
qui me préoccupe plus depuis longtemps
nous fait disons que je crois à l'au
delà dans le sens où je suis en train de
faire quelque chose qui pour moi est
plus important que la réussite mais
immédiate enfin que le succès qu la
gloire immédiat ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que dans cinquante ans des gens qui
fassent tourner mes disques pour
l'entente de ma voix qu'on raconte ont
pas cette interview c'est dérisoire
je pense papier spécial mange pas son
personnage je pensais la survie je pense
à sarah bernhardt qui avait
que les gens adoraient qui était pleine
de charme malgré plein de problèmes
je crois que j'ai longtemps cru que
d'être forte c'était un problème que
c'était un petit peu en nommant une
phase une agressivité aussi j'ai
longtemps cru d'état de chaud et c'était
faux y'a pas de problème quand on veut
vraiment on veut quand on est décidé
quand on veut être qu'on peut être et
prendre les vraiment il n'ya jamais de
problème pour persévérer jusqu'à la
déraison c'est toujours d'inverser les
genres avec le cardinal daniélou je
parle des femmes avec régine je parle de
dieu je trouve que je crois j'ai gens se
retrouvent tous les gens se retrouvent
avec mon vrai d'ailleurs pourquoi je ne
croyais pas en dieu et ryad terrienne
différend
avec le cardinal
pénible du pape pie ix a pas de raisons
je crois en dieu
absolument et je crois en tout cas à
quelque chose je crois qu'il faut avoir
la foi c'est d'une importance
fabuleuse enfin les gens qui ne croient
en rien faut croire en l'homme qu'on
aime ou alors à son enfant ou à sebha
obligatoire mon dieu c'est croire aux
choses qui sont là qui confesse sur le
moment et où avant ou après en fait je
pars tout cas jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
il faut croire à quelque chose vous avez
un besoin d'apprendre oui je suis
extrêmement curieuse je suis
je suis je suis une fille qu'il n'a pas
été en fin de compte à l'école d'une
façon permanente si vous voulez je n'ai
pas eu une culture
très profonde et je n'y crois pas je
crois que
l'intelligence et surtout l'instinct et
la
l'humanité enfin de le besoin de chaleur
humaine et le besoin d'écouter les
autres et de comprendre les plus
importants que la culture
quels sont vos lectures
angers des lectures très diverses est
prêt
je lis je mélange
papillon
c'est à l'âme c'est à la mode je mélange
papillon dans l'âge prévu sur jésus
papillon comme tout le monde
je lis j'ai lu zola j'disais l'âge dit
proulx ce jeudi le marquis de sade julie
jeudi à peu près tout tout et n'importe
comment
absolument pas pour des raisons défini
n'importe comment
d'accord mais pas n'importe quoi
j'ai lu non parce que n'importe quoi on
te fait deux pages et puis on termine
enfin je veux dire que c'est difficile
de dire le n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
si vous n'êtes pas accroché au bout de
dix pages sica enfin c'est rarement dans
vos origines j'ai l'impression qu'on
vous connais mal on dit partout que vous
êtes une bagarreuse une fois on s'est un
peu vrai mais vous êtes sûrement très
faible
mais toutes les femmes sont faibles tous
les êtres humains sont fait voler tous
on est tous des gens on est tous des
êtres que d'une seconde à l'autre sont
appelés à disparaître cela cela vous
romantique d'ailleurs ça va ensemble
moi je crois que tous les deux oui
j'suis slave et romantique et en même
temps extrêmement réaliste et c'est pour
ça que j'aime cela je me suis toujours
demandé comment une femme pouvait venir
à bout d'une boîte de nuit
alain club mettant c'est beaucoup plus
facile que vous ne le croyez car la
notion de boîte de nuit ne plus rien à
voir avec ce que c'était
jacques vous êtes déjà venu dans mon cru
vous savez comment c'est c'est presque
familiale phase est venue presque
familiale il ya les parents il ya des
enfants et à les cousins et cousines y
est tout nous à tout un tas de gens
c'est un endroit très gai une famille
pour moi oui mais ça n'est pas aux gens
qui viennent que je pense c'est par
exemple à ce qu'on appelle ce que nous
sommes convenu d'appeler la mafia de la
nuit y a pas de mafia la nuit ya des
gens et des noctambules et des êtres
perdus dans la journée ne se sont pas
bien le hêtre noctambules ne veut pas
dire sortir la nuit pour boire un verre
et pour noctambules c'est vraiment être
décidés à aller se coucher plus tard
possible
parce que on écoute jusqu'à la dernière
minute les gens qui parlent on regarde
les choses ça je dirais oui mais c'est
le dodo à la dernière minute parce qu'il
n'existe pas
beaucoup plus méfiant entre contre les
gens qui vont se coucher devant ce que
jetterai pas un matin non mais je moi je
pensais au racket qu'elle raquette ça
existe le racket nom fameux parler
duquel raquette j'ai pas très vivant
comme l'amérique par exemple j'ai
entendu parler d'autre chose
ricky blitt et je crois qu'on a sonné il
faut donner un pourcentage un certain
nombre de personnages
l'annoncé jeu très gourmande moi j'ai
pas question que je partage avec qui que
ce soit
régine s'il vous fallait choisir un jour
entre votre club est votre métier qui
est aujourd'hui la chanson eh bien
écoutez je vous dirais que je de la
santé
la force de faire les deux donc le mais
nécessaire expliqué je me suis fabriqué
une famille
parce qu en fait j'en avais pas ou très
peu
et je pourrais difficilement vivre loin
de la france je pourrais difficilement
vivre
à chanteur ou une chanteuse est
obligatoirement noctambules je veux dire
qu'on termine à minuit on va dîner on
traîne jusqu'à 4 heures du matin
moi je fais la même chose je le fais
dans mon club sir je chante pas dans le
club quand je vais chanter
soit l'olympia soit ailleurs j'ai fini
et minuit minuit et demi c'est
merveilleux pour mon régime car je ne
mange pas presse que je traîne on et gdf
tabanou et jeu nerveux je suis traqueuse
que j'aime je vais mon club c'est tout
je me détends me défoule la danse est
importante pour moi en tout cas c'est un
c'est un atout fabuleux et c'est une
grand vainqueur vous danserez l'encore
que dans 20 ans dans 50 ans entend jean
sera encore et j'espère que la france en
titre dans son île monde entier ce qui
est embêtant c'est de voir des gens
assis sur leur derrière pour une soirée
entière faut faire n'importe quoi mais
faut se défouler il faut danser c'est
nécessaire ccco comportement on interdit
aux jeunes gens là et danser le fait de
leur interdire cette via une chose
absolument
qu'ils ont envie de faire
automatiquement que si on leur dit à
partir de 14 ans on leur donnait des
cours de danse des cours de danse
moderne venir l'un prenait danser le
tango la valse quand il commencera à
sortir votre une chose tellement laissé
tellement naturel de connaître déjà le
couple en fall ça ne deviendrait plus
une chose interdite ni
je crois que ça fait laissé sa famille
cela faciliterait beaucoup les choses
régine votre réussite ce qui est
inattendu
écoutez le mou réussite personnellement
m'ennuie je lui ai déjà dit la réussite
une chose éphémère il faut tous les
jours on est en bas de la pente moi je
me réveille tous les jours et tous les
jours chauds en bas de la pente je
considère qu'en bas de la pente et tous
les jours il faut que je monte et non
pas que je monte pour monter enfin je
vous expliquer c'est parce que je crois
que tous les jours on apprend quelque
chose tous les jours et quelque chose de
nouveau qui se passe et qu'il faut être
au courant qu'il faut être dans ce
quelque chose
c'est si vitale si votre bonheur de
femmes vous
exigez plutôt de vous que vous
abandonniez tout le reste
j'ai pris la décision de me marier parce
que je suis
fiancée depuis un certain temps avec un
garçon qui a parfaitement compris le
personnage que je suis
est autrement je me verrais pas
exigeante
les hommes les femmes on doit d'être
exigeant l'un vis-à-vis de l'autre c'est
leur droit elles doivent l'être
autrement après c'est l'ennui
pourquoi ne pas être pareil ou au bout
de dix ans qu'au bout d'un an c'est
parce que justement tout devient acquis
tout et
c'est ce qui fait que beaucoup de gens
nous disons non plus rien à se dire un
couple c'est surtout une complicité un
couple ça doit être de l'amitié de la
tendresse du rire et de l'amour bien
entendu une certaine compréhension au
bout d'un certain temps messieurs parce
que les aventures de l'existence qui
sont là et je ne pense pas que ça
doivent briser automatiquement une vie
j'ai l'impression vous serez très
jalouse des coûts seraient mariés j'ai
toujours été jalouse je suis jalouse de
mes amis je jalouse de mon fiancé
jalouse de mon fihg
c'est tout je suis une vraie femme avec
ce que ça comporte mais j'ai pas une
mauvaise jalousie chine jalousie
proportionnée
régine je le sais votre meilleur public
ce sont les enfants
oui c'est un phénomène qui m'a qui m'a
beaucoup épaté au départ et je me
souviens avoir dit à quelqu'un que je ne
nommerai pas
attention vous allez avoir un tournant
parce que il n'y a pas de raison que les
chansons que je chante attire tel nombre
de cas face aux courriers que je reçois
tous les jours un courrier d'enfants et
g10 passe quelque chose et une oreille
nouvelle qui est en train de se faire et
quelque chose de nouveau qui est en
train d'arriver c'était au moment des
petits papiers
du même nom on est en plein dans l'oeil
et enfin j'ai dit moi j'ai un problème
je suis pour les jambes liverpool
puisque je lance toutes les nouvelles
danses et pour l'autre moitié du corps
que vous disiez je suis une chanteuse
populaire nomade où je suis pas un homme
parce que je suis petit et malgré mes
origines et ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure je crois que rester profondément
une fille de la rue
je veux dire je comprends tout ce qui se
passe dans la rue je suis aux aguets je
suis là je suis
le problème je vis enfin je suis
quelqu'un qui fait partie de tout ce qui
est
le pavé de paris régine vous chantez
avec le même bonheur la même humeur dans
les salons du 16e et à la fête de
l'humanité je trouvais ça parfaitement
je ne chante pas dans les salons du 16e
car on vous demande rarement que chanter
dans les salons du 16e moi je chante ou
ya la foule y a pas assez de monde dans
les salons du 16e
moi je suis une chanteuse populaire je
n'ai pas de message à délivrer je chante
des chansons gaies triste qui font
pleurer qui font rire donne un petit
pincement
sao d'humour et je vais où il ya du
monde et oui à la foule c'est tout ce
qui m'intéresse la rue tessa qu'est ce
que c'est pour vous le tout-paris
tout-paris lier ces timbres faris est
devenu fallu tout paraît que ça veut
dire ça vous savez aussi bien que moi
c'est un mélange énorme et de gens et
c'est pour ça que c'est tout paris
régine vous avez maintenant à trouville
à deux villes et dans le fond c'est une
revanche à la fois femme et toi de ville
s'était pas de lille non c'est une
revanche sur votre jeunesse quand
j'étais petit j'allais toujours à
trouver les casinos partout il ya des
casinos moi de toute façon j'étais
puisque mon père jouait je voulais me
voir à l'époque c'était trouville
traverser le pont c'était un luxe c'est
deauville quand j'avais
13 ans 14 enfin 14 enjeu plus faste et
tout de suite après la guerre
puisque c'est de ce moment je me
rappelle de trouville où je devais me va
avoir 15 ans je me souviens un jour m
arrêter parce qu'il est plein de monde
devant la régence je me suis arrêté j'ai
regardé et avaient ri taylor tu
es allé quand
je me suis dit qu'est-ce que je
donnerais pas pour manger la cetera
c'est qu'on me regarde
et puis ça m'est arrivé
j'ai mieux faire la cuisine chez moi
pour mes copains
car ça veut rien dire c'est comme la
chanson de tout à l'heure ça ne veut
rien dire d'avoir réussi d'être dans le
luxe ça veut rien dire
ça veut dire
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses et ça ne
veut rien dire je veux dire sur le
canton négoce et qu'on rêve de devenir
secours ce que tu as envie qu'on y
arrive
je veux dire que ça n'a pas la même ça
n'a pas la même proportion que ce qu'on
pense quand on est gosse évidemment tout
et tout et imaginative prend des
proportions énormes pour moi ce qu'ils
mangeaient étaient des choses absolument
qu'on ne devait pas pouvoir s'acheter
dans la vie réelle des des choses
ahurissantes enfin le homard à la nage
c'était j'avais l'impression qu'il
fallait préparer sa demi jours à
l'avancé que c'était vraiment quelque
chose d'inouï quoi si vous voulez je
vous donne la recette du homard a nagé
une simplicité
pour vous régine la foule c'est votre
drogue pour lutter contre la solitude
car dans le fond je crois que vous êtes
un personnage assez solitaire à ses
secrets
oui c'est une façon de lutter je vous ai
dit que je me donne des coups de pied au
derrière temps en temps car j'aurai une
tendance me
replier on vient des champions en
perpétuelle lutte avec moi même je ne
m'accorde pas de repos alors
par exemple rien qui me prête je
pourrais rester dans l'élite à
tranquille
et puis lire et puis et tout d'un coup
je me lève suprise de frénésie et je
téléphone à 40 personnes et puis voilà
j'organise je fais je vais je viens je
me dis mais alors pourquoi
régine vous n'aimez pas le psn vous
n'aimez pas le mot réussite mais
physiquement vous êtes une réussite
que vous appelez physiquement ça a été
dur vous avez maigri vous avez suivi un
régime c'est à dire la vérité ça n'a pas
été si dur que ça et en fait il fallait
que je fasse complètement les choses qui
me plaisait pour ça m'arrive car quand
on veut maigrir on maigrit y ait pas de
problème est qu'à pas bouffer
donc quand on veut on peut maigrir
moi je me suis pas vraiment privé
l'expliqué le régime que j'ai fait j'en
ai fait 3-1 qui le régit misaine qui est
un régime aussi psychologique ce set in
nouveau pour moi
j'ai mangé du riz du riz sauvage midi et
soir autant que j'en voulais
je me suis dis tous les jours c'est
formidablement bon jeu faisait cuire 5
des petits oignons une huile spéciale
des petites carottes et je faisais du
homard à la nage ou de tout plat pour
mes copains pour mes amis parce que
j'adore faire la cuisine et je me voyais
manger savait qu'une tel appétit qu ils
vont regarder une étude fait goûter donc
en fait les choeurs et qu à se
convaincre eux j'ai fait le régime
dissocié
qui est de manger un jour un plat et
d'aller jusqu'au bout c'est à dire si
vous avez décidé de manger un steak
aujourd'hui font manger du steak toute
la journée demain ce sera des légumes
après demain des lits des fruits le
surlendemain des laitages bien et puis
un troisième régime qui est celui des
sportifs
jeux valve des graines
de petites cuillères de graines qui qui
grossissent dans mon estomac une heure
avant le repas et je mange à peu près
tout mais très peu parce que j'ai plus
de place voilà vous avez fait tout cela
pour avoir du chant ou pour être
simplement une femme non j'ai fait tout
ça parce que je croyais que c'était
nécessaire
pour monter sur scène était complexée me
disais bon alors je vais chanter des
belles chansons puis tout d'un coup dur
a quand même alors elle est grosse
et ça m'emmerdait j'avais envie et puis
dans le fond c'était idiot je reçois des
lettres gens vous disent ah bon vous
êtes drôlement mieux vous étiez plus
grosse
le jour en fin de compte je crois qu'il
faut être cru ce qu'on ait enfin j'ai
pas envie de regrossir je me mettrais
pas manger pour grossir je crois que je
ne pourrai plus mais j'ai pas envie de
devenir plus maigres je suis pas
maigrichonne je suis encore bien
regina quoi il ya une phrase de vous qui
est significative c'est lorsque vous
dites les hommes sortent avec les femmes
maigres et rentrer avec des bouts lot
non j'ai pas dit ça comme ça les 10 dans
un film
jeudi dans un film
et la forêt a été tourné par mois parce
qu'elle n'était pas dite de cette façon
je dis que les hommes sortaient avec les
maigres avec les mains c'est rentrer et
avec les rondes ce qui est souvent la
vérité
pourquoi il ya que les hommes qui
peuvent répondre c'est à vous gérez
votre avis régime quel genre de femme
aime les hommes écoutez moi je crois que
les hommes aiment les femmes qui ont du
charme et point final et c'est tout et
qu'aucun homme ne résiste est une femme
qui a du charme régimes les plus les
petits papiers je crois que c'est l'une
de vos plus belles chansons les petits
par les petits papiers ont marqué ont
marqué le vrai le vrai départ enfin
disons demain ma carrière c'est mon
deuxième disque des petits papiers sur
celui là y'avait il fera par jour ne
fait pas de l'oeil et lili la grande zoa
trop de bonnes chansons trop de bonnes
chansons on me reproche beaucoup de
faire trop de bonnes chansons les les
programmateurs sap à laquelle passe et
ce qui fait qu'il ya pas une ni tenine
matraquage paraît-il
mais je préfère qu'on reproche de faire
trop de bonnes chansons c'est pas un
c'est pas grand reproche régime qu'est
ce que c'est pour vous l'argent
coûter l'argent c'est ce que j'ai rêvé
d'avoir
tout le temps j'en ai pas eu
ces thèmes acheter plein de chaussure
surtout des chaussures parce que j'ai
porté des chaussures de bois j'aime
danser que je ne regarde mes jambes que
pour moi l'idée que je pourrais apporter
les chaussures de bois est absolument
des traumatismes pouvant table ce qui
fait que j'achète beaucoup de chaussures
des chaussures des chaussures des
chaussures c'est presque une maladie une
de vos amis me disaient que c'étaient
les chauffeurs de taxi qui est entre
donner votre légende elle chauffeur de
taxi raconte ma vie mon fils est arrivé
l'autre jour en disant que je me suis
bien amusé et j'ai pris un taxi je
médiane les mois
là auprès du boulevard montparnasse
et
de du 16e arrondissement au boulevard
montparnasse qui lui a raconté ma vie
c'était très drôle d'une certaine
manière je ne vous êtes encore un peu
snob
mais goûter
ma concierge et snob ma suzanne que j'ai
depuis 20 ans une has no bismes vous
savez que j'ai eu un berger allemand
pendant longtemps qui est une bête
magnifique que j'adorais qui mord tiens
y'a pas longtemps et 8 mois
et je suis rentré d'allemagne et huit
jours je dormais à moitié dans ce taxi
je m'étais levé 5h45 du matin j'avais
enregistré toute la nuit j'ai entendu
aboyer j'ai vu doc store ça m'a fait
rire puis j'ai vu une boule noire et
blanche au milieu d'un tas de chiens
pareil marron j'ai dit je vais aller
voir ce que c'est que ce chien et j'ai
trouvé un chien absolument qui ressemble
un de mes pyjama comme sage un pyjama
rayé noir et blanc c'est un tibétain de
chiens chinois
très bizarre et je les ramener à la
maison
la réaction de ma suzanne je voulais
donner car c'est vraiment le snobisme
dans la plus grande que votre suzanne
mais suzanne neptune d'hommes et ma
nounou si vous voulez quand j'habitais
la porte dorée qui ne l'est pas d'argent
il venait faire le ménage une heure par
semaine chez moi puis quand mes fonds
augmentait
elle a fait deux heures par semaine et
puis trois heures par semaine et puis
quatre heures par semaine et puis cinq
heures par semaine et puis au fur et à
mesure de mon ascension elle est montée
avec moi et quand je partis de la porte
dorée elle est venue travailler
complètement avec moi ya 18 ans non
alors quelle a été la réaction de votre
réaction a été la suivante elle a dit
vous ne vous imaginez pas qu'après va
promener une bête aussi belle que mon
faust je vais des premiers cette espèce
de chose je changerai de trottoir je
crois que c'est la réflexion la plus
noble que j'ai entendu
régine vous croyez beaucoup à
l'astrologie beaucoup vous en abusez des
noms je n'abuse pas je suis une je suis
moi même un peu médium
et je croise trop le gie je crois aux
signes je crois aux événements je crois
aux fluides aux événements qui vont
arriver je les sens d' avance on avait
tout prévu pour vous tous prédit
mais vraiment où c'est du cinéma non non
vraiment vraiment donc toujours y est je
vous envoie faire une petite cure
donc convaincu vous savez ce qui va vous
arriver maintenant c'est oui l'émission
va se terminer et puis on va nous ont
pas du tout dans la vie de régine vous
devez savoir plus et vous savez ce qui
s'est passé vous connaissez
je sais je sais à peu près dans les
grandes lignes ce qui fait marrer il est
brillant
comment il est brillant cet avenir
c'est exact forte
quand je suis parti sûr c'est que ça
pour toujours malheur de parler des
choses avant
dix ans que je sais ce qui va m'arriver
quelle est la chose que vous regrettez
le plus
de pas avoir eu plus d'enfants un moment
où j'étais plus plus disponibles plus
plis pour d'esprit de
où c'était une chose peut-être plus
plus normal que maintenant je voudrais
je voudrais avoir d'autres enfants je
n'aurais sûrement mais je regrette de
prendre avoir eu plus un moment j'étais
disponible complètement vous avez une
vocation de mère de famille j'adore les
enfants
une femme d'intérieur j'adore décor est
interne on veut
je regrette de pas avoir eu plus
d'enfants vous ne vous voyez pas
prochainement dans un couvent je ne sais
pas ce qu'on vous a dit 6 pourquoi pas
dans un couvent par ce n'est pas ma
religion en main je me convertis ce qui
peut qui pourrait très bien rire lorsque
le découvrons j'appelle sa retraite si
possible est fort possible que je
termine mon existence seul dans un
endroit qui rame en désert et que je
n'adresse plus la parole jamais à
personne pourquoi pas parce que vous
auriez lyon de quelque chose que du tout
parce que tout d'un coup je considérerai
que ce que j'avais à faire je les fais
et eux
mais je crois que je ne t'ai
l'emmerdeuse que que je vais rester là
très longtemps enfin je renoncerai
jamais ses positions vous avez
aujourd'hui régine vous l'avez mérité
je crois je travaille beaucoup et je
crois que je le mériterai
les positions sont différentes dans la
vie et des chants qui hérite milliards
et une position une série de ça parce
que leur grand père leur père en leurs
parents ont travaillé pose moi tous créé
je le mérite par moi-même
pendant des heures de présence de
travail je considère que c'est très très
méritée régine par deux les modes pasm
va vous demander quels sont vos projets
mais ce n'est pas le style je dis cela
les projets ce n'est qu'au moment où les
faits nous avons passé 60 minutes
ensemble je vous remercie régine enfin
jacques
[Musique]